Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast?
I know it isn't.
What am I talking about?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast dead.
I'm just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in to see how your God Damn Day is going.
I know lately the podcast who spend a little bit quiet.
I understand.
All right.
I was transitioning from one part of the country to another part of the country.
I didn't have my,
my technologies with me,
speaking of technology now these fucking movies that I want to see right now and
I just don't have the God damn time.
I want to see that Mr. Rogers movie.
I want to see mission impossible and I want to see,
uh,
it was some movie called eighth grade where they were like,
this is what it's like to be an eighth grader and the during the social media
time I'm like,
oh,
I should see that.
You know,
cause I need to relate to some young people.
So my jokes keep working with them.
I mean,
not eighth graders,
but you know,
in a blink of an eye,
the way I'm aging,
that kid will be in fucking college,
right?
You can't ignore the youth,
the ignore the EUC.
You grow old with your fucking crowd.
And then next thing you know,
you're doing shows at three in the afternoon on a little fucking booze cruise
going around the marina.
You know,
five foot two eyes are blue,
but oh,
what those five foots could do.
Are you singing that song has,
hey,
hey Shane,
shame right up there in some fucking mustard stain,
tuxedos yelling at your agent plays to sell tickets to this town.
They ain't happen.
And to me,
um,
I'll tell you what did happen to me.
This is very embarrassing and it's of a physical nature.
It's a part of my body.
And this is a time when I feel everybody has been emoting and,
and we've gotten rid of the shame.
So I just want it.
Before I tell you this,
I just want to thank all of you
for being considerate and thoughtful of my feelings during this difficult time.
All right.
So my,
my sciatic nerves
came back.
Oh,
it came back with a vengeance because I didn't keep going to the muscles to keep
fucking making sure you know,
that,
you know,
whatever the fuck happened the first time it didn't happen again and it got all
messed up again.
And uh,
we were trying to figure out what triggers it and like,
well,
flying helicopters,
you know,
I fly the smallest one that exists,
so there's,
there's nothing about it that's has to do with comfort.
It all has to do with weight and balance and get in the fucking thing off the
ground.
As long as you can sit down,
they don't give a shit if you're on a bed of nails.
And I think it's just maybe that,
that's what's aggravating it.
She's like,
all right,
what else you got?
I played drums.
I'll sit there for an hour,
an hour and a half trying to figure out how their cute little Asian girl played
good times,
bad times,
so easily,
effortlessly.
Right.
What else?
I sit in a writer's room,
I fly in planes and all that type of shit.
And she goes,
all right.
She was listening and then she just basically told me,
okay,
in,
you know that my problem is,
is I have no ass.
Over the years I've just sat down so long,
what little ass I had is now gone.
So a bill,
Billy,
no goop,
no glutes,
right?
Is Al Pachino would say he's got no ass.
Right?
So it's just,
it's just essentially bones,
nerves,
veins and arteries and skin.
There's no muscle tone back there.
I basically have Michael Douglas's ass in basic instinct,
whatever that one was when he was like fucking 65 and decided to do the yet.
Remember that was like a big thing with like white guys back then,
be it happy in an old guy and just showing your ass Dennis Franz on fucking Nyp
de Blue,
fucking uh,
Michael Douglas in basic NC state.
One of those movies where he was just fucking throwing chicks around,
which you could never do anymore.
Like it was just,
he was beating them and fucking them at the same time.
And I'll tell you the bride's back in the day,
they loved it.
It was considered a hot seat nowadays.
Oh Jesus.
What was that couch made of?
Dead.
He bent her over.
Was that fucking medata ostrich for
that's offensive to women and nature right now.
I don't know what you do.
I don't know.
I haven't seen a love seat in this new progressive time.
I imagine the guy is sitting there with his hands folded.
They skills bay.
Would it be all right if I
okay.
Leaned across the table and got a little closer to you.
I'm offended.
Um,
anyways,
what am I talking about here?
So I have to do some fucking squats,
you know,
and I got a bone bruise.
I'm falling apart here.
People.
I've got a bone bruise on my left knee because my beautiful daughter or I'm
loving as I'm teaching her how to play catch.
And we've got this giant bag of these plastic balls,
right?
And I think she's right handed,
which I'm not going to lie to you.
I want her to be a lefty.
If you're a lefty,
you can get to the show with an 85 mile an hour fast ball.
We all know it.
Okay?
You start throwing right handed.
You got to come with the gas.
It's gotta be fucking,
I don't know,
it's gotta be like fucking 102 miles an hour at this point.
So anyways,
she just,
she'll pick up two at a time and then she runs at me and just throws them both
at the same time.
And I just play like goalie and we got had wood floors and I was crawling around
on the hardwood on my knees and uh,
I dunno,
I thought I fucking towards something,
but thank God yesterday I found out it's just a bone bruise so it's going away.
But um,
yeah,
so he is a big deal.
I gotta I have to go on the Internet and I got to make sure I do my squats
right.
Okay.
And I have to get my pasty flat ass.
I got to get some padding back there or evidently this is going to,
it's going to become even worse.
You know what I mean?
I've decided that I'm going to get fucking,
uh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to get my ass back.
I've decided that rather than be that old white guy who has the inflatable
cushion that he fucking sits on,
I can't be that guy.
You know what I mean?
Taking people up in a helicopter,
like looking like a Badass and like,
hang on a second guys,
just fucking man.
You know,
everybody just loses all confidence.
Does this guy know how to fly this fucking thing?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
that's my deal.
You know,
and I'm also a child of the 80s and you know,
who's kidding who?
Let's all be honest.
Nobody did legs in the fucking eighties unless you're a bodybuilder.
Everybody just,
you barely even did your back.
You know,
everybody was just fucking,
everybody just did like,
what are your bedsheets?
What you been doing dirty?
Put Up to 25 fucking 36 ties.
Kay could try out for the patch dove,
right?
That's all it was about.
And it was,
I'll tell you,
you go to a fucking gym,
all right?
And if you have to bench,
you're waiting for the B.
Going to stand there like a line at Starbucks at like eight in the fucking
morning waiting to get on the bench.
But I'll tell you where there's no fucking,
I'll tell you right now with is no line.
You go into the leg room.
Oh my God.
It's like walking into a furniture store.
Go ahead buddy.
Try them all out.
See which one you like.
Right?
It's like going into light and leave the purple building.
Does that play still exist?
Um,
I'm making a lot of Boston references and you probably like,
why bill?
Are Ya?
Oh,
you fucking cunt.
The battery thing just fucking beat.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I swear to God,
I just can't get a God damn fucking break.
Abs going to talk to this runs out,
I guess in 43 seconds.
42 seconds.
I'm talking Boston ship because the,
uh,
the Yankees,
oh,
when the Yankees come to town,
the red sox Yankees stats tonight and uh,
prices and in and judges out,
right?
But all they're missing as a hitter.
We mentioned missing our star Pitcher and I needed that guy cause I got,
I got a hundred bucks riding on every game with these two different Yankee fans.
50 bucks each.
I need a price to go in there and shut those fucking pin.
Stripe comes down.
Now we don't have our ace and in uh,
not price with the fuck am I talking about?
Uh,
the other guy,
their prices.
The Guy I need not to fuck.
All right,
I'm back.
You know what?
It wasn't a battery issue.
It was,
the memory was full full of me running my fucking Yap.
I'm sitting there.
Same prices out.
A sale is out.
Is it Chris Sale?
I've only been on the bandwagon here for the last month.
He's out.
He said he had something that's been building something that's been bothering
him.
You know what'd you get your period?
Um,
he can't play
fucking a Mike Judge.
Aaron judge is out for the Yankees,
right?
He's standing there like a fucking Paul Bunyan.
I mean,
how do you not hit the guy?
Jesus Christ,
he's like the size of the goddamn backstop.
Get a bone chip in the palm of his hand.
Isn't that amazing?
A guy that,
that fucking pig,
all you have to do is throw a ball at his hand and all of a sudden he can't play
a game of baseball.
I mean,
you're talking about a guy who could literally rip the pillars out of the
fucking parking lot,
you know,
and then you hit him in the hand.
He's like,
how am I going to play Patty cake?
I can't come out for the red sox series,
but you know,
that is the history of the Yankees.
You know what I mean?
You know,
they got a lot of free agent guys and they're all really soft,
just like a,
all their fans out in the bleachers.
All those fatties out there that do the roll call.
Like that's the big thing in life,
fe area and wave at us.
It was neck fat,
fucking jerk offs out there.
Um,
it's unbelievable that you can have a team that,
that's,
that's successful,
that they would,
they would,
uh,
be involved in something.
Well,
I just don't get it.
I don't get the fucking why MCA.
I don't get why we have a fucking mascot.
I don't get why we sing sweet Caroline.
I don't,
you know what it is that they're trying to get rid of the animals.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
the Yankees fans,
they borderline doing a fucking musical.
I thought it was an advertisement for that.
What was that show they had all those years?
Uh,
with the puppets avenue Q.
That's what I thought it was.
I was looking at the scoreboard going said,
coming out of that.
No,
those are full grown adult males.
Oh.
[inaudible] good.
You roll call or
get alive.
We're going to say your name until you acknowledge us.
And I know I'm coming down hard on the Yankee fans.
I realized this is not all of you guys.
This is all he fucking 12% of you,
um,
with your little gang of baseball fans.
But as much as I do that,
I don't think anything is worse than watch should fucking Dude Dubai Buddo do
Bateau and that song comes on.
You see all those women putting their head on their boyfriend.
You know what I mean?
That right dead that moment there is why women in general are not in positions
of power.
They sit there,
they try to blame guys specifically bald blue eyed white males like myself,
which by the way,
I'm really offended.
Okay.
I mean,
and I got to tell you something right now.
If I hear one more feminist interrupting my privilege during the day,
me just walking through one open door after another and I have to listen to her
fucking rhetoric.
I swear to God I am.
I am going to,
I will pull all of my money out of the stock market and cause it to crash money
that I didn't earn money that was given to me from my ancestors by stealing it
from people who did not look like me.
Okay.
Sorry,
I'm just steering into the stereotype.
Um,
oh really built.
We thought you were fucking serious.
Uh,
what am I talking about here?
This is why women,
it's so many of them do not attain a position of power because all you have to
do is put on sweet Caroline and it makes them want to tilt their head and put it
on their man's shoulder.
Okay?
That is not leadership quality.
That's,
that's what the fuck I would do if I was running a company right now and God
knows it be all this fucking pressure as the guy who started the company to step
aside and let a woman run it,
Z can act like you're fucking progressive.
You know what I mean?
Where are the ladies when it's all being built?
They're nowhere to be found then when it's built,
hey,
we want to do it tow.
Now that you completed it.
We want to fly planes too.
Now that all the guys died and we figured out what not to fucking dope.
No offense to Amelia Earhart,
the chick that fucking,
uh,
also crushed it,
but for some reason nobody talks about her.
Um,
I talking about,
I'm just fucking around everybody.
I have no problem with people of Eddie.
Fuck it back.
Grab the epitope.
It though.
Um,
where am I?
Let me,
uh,
let me,
let me complete this.
Okay.
I have to do a fucking radio tour for two hours starting at eight minutes.
And how long have I done in the podcast?
Is it going to work out with a math workout?
Nine in five are 14,
son of a bitch.
I still got half a podcast to go.
I'm gonna have to wait.
Wait till the end of this shit.
Um,
Oh bill,
why are you doing a radio tour?
Because I'm promoting rough and rowdy going to be in Youngstown,
Ohio.
All right.
There's no women.
They're putting their heads on their guy's shoulder.
They put their head,
their ear does the guy's chest after they hit him with a fucking pen and make
sure it's fucking heart's still pumping.
Okay.
I'm talking a tough town and Youngstown.
It's going to be great.
We got pride versus prejudice.
All right?
We have a gay man who's fighting a convicted felon who does not like gay people.
We got a cop fight and a skateboarder,
and now we've got a bunch of Cleveland Brown fans getting in the ring with
Pittsburgh Steeler fans.
And that God knows the browns cannot beat the Steelers on the grid iron.
But can the people of Cleveland beat up the people of Pittsburgh?
Now you'd think generally speaking,
the people of Pittsburgh are a little softer than the people in Cleveland.
All right?
They have six super bowl titles.
They haven't had a fucking steel mill in generations out there.
Okay.
I've gone there.
It's a tech city now.
All right?
They got all the beautiful bridges.
They got rid of three rivers.
The team plays on natural grass now.
I mean,
it's one of the quaintness towns you'll ever go to.
Nobody can walk up this fucking hill.
So they got a God damn elevator trolley thing that brings you up.
I think Pittsburgh is ripe for the taking
and uh,
go to rough and rowdy brawl to order the fight.
I'm telling you right now,
hang with the recorded or hanging that night with your buddies.
Watch it.
It's going to be a,
I will be commentating,
forgot to mention that,
that says a little cherry in there that I just throw.
Okay.
Little fucking sugar cube.
Oh freckles.
We'll be sitting down on his lack of an ass evidently.
And uh,
I'll be there with the big cat in the El Pres.
Uh,
two wonderful individuals,
you know,
who are preventing a lot of bar fights.
I feel,
I feel like,
um,
people with headgear and gloves are going to be able to get all their
frustrations out.
It's going to be a wonderful night of entertainment.
I am not going to miss a second of it and um,
you know,
I would appreciate it if you guys would order it.
It would make me look good if I could help pump up their fucking numbers.
I love what they do over there.
I hope you do too.
If you do,
please order the fight and that's the end of this problem.
How do you like that?
And right the day before the fucking fight,
I'm going to be in Rochester,
New York home mystique for Gad,
or at least he played with the Rochester Crusaders according to his,
according to his drum instructional video that I actually own on VHS and on DVD.
All right.
I never could commit to the laser disc.
I was afraid of unpopular technologies.
After Robert Kelly talked me into getting a mini disc player,
which I still have with the t shaped microphone.
I can't find the chat,
but I have all these little fucking cassettes of uh,
you know,
wherever many cds of my sets from years gone by and I want to listen to them.
And people like,
well,
why don't you take him somewhere?
It's like,
cause I have no idea what I'm saying on these fucking thanks.
All right.
I used to mutter to myself between sets,
throwing out all kinds of crazy shit and in this fucking today's climate,
God knows what,
what the shit you said fucking,
um,
when we're talking 20 years ago,
been 20 years ago,
I was dating this woman.
I used to literally drag around the city by her hair and nobody had a problem
with it.
Okay.
You think I'm going to dump off my fucking mini display or to somebody,
you outta your mind.
It's not happening.
All right.
Anyways,
so I am a
hey,
by the way,
guess what?
I made another month,
month of July,
not a drop of booze,
not one fucking drop.
You've got damp cuts and uh,
it really affected my mood.
Okay.
I was in such a good mood when I would wake up in the morning,
but I was so grumpy at night,
you know,
just happened to sit there and fucking
stare at the wall.
Um,
I,
it's weird like this,
this time of day,
I don't miss it,
but at night I definitely,
you know,
you get into it with your wife or a,
I don't know,
your parents looking at you in a weird way.
You just need something to take the edge off and I got to tell you a Rosetta
stone French just isn't doing it.
Um,
all right.
Do I get time to do one read?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'll do one region and then I got to do this tour and then,
then I'll be back and I'll let you know how it goes.
Okay,
everybody hanging on my every word?
Gi Bill.
How is your radio tour going to go?
All right,
here we go.
He looks everybody Elyx.
Maybe I can get through this in three minutes.
That'd be fucking great.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
Little fucking so.
So why would you buy a generic mattress built for everyone else?
What do you,
the hunchback and Neil.
The dean.
Yeah.
Next,
please mention all the talking points below.
Oh,
absolutely.
He looks sleep matches your body to the perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life life.
They've developed nine different mattresses tailored to specific body types and
sleep preferences.
Just go to helix,
how asleep.com/bird take their two minutes sleep quiz and the match you to the
mattress that that's perfect for you.
Contouring to your body,
cupping your balls,
squeezing your lack of an ass to provide unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
36% of headaches.
Sleep.
Customers report better sleep after switching to their customized mattress from
helix sleep.
Uh,
right now they're offering up to $125 off all mattresses.
Mattress Ortis,
whether you're a side sleeper,
a hearts
like a plush or affirm bed,
they got the mattress that will fit just right.
Get up to $125 off he looks.
sleep.com/burr that's heloc sleep.com/bar for $125 off your mattress order.
He looks sleek.com/barb.
All right,
quick everybody.
All right.
The truth is most of us are brushing our teeth wrong,
not long enough and forget to change
our brush on time.
Former porn stars,
gagging on it.
That's because most brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing but not quip.
So what makes quip so different?
You may not have asked.
Uh,
please mention I'll talking points below.
Of course I'm going to for quip as an electric toothbrush,
that's a fraction of the cost of the bulkier brushes while still packing just
the right amount of vibration to help clean your gross teeth.
You listening.
England quips built in timer helps you clean for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with guiding pulses that reminds you when to switch
side.
Next quips subscription plans are for your health,
not just convenience.
They deliver new brush heads on a dentist.
Recommended schedule every three months for just $5,
including free shipping worldwide.
Quip also comes with a mount that's suctions right to your mirror and unstick to
use as a cover for hygienic travel wherever you take your teeth.
Uh,
and finally,
everyone loves quip.
Evidently they were on Oprah's Olis.
I love this time named one of the Times best inventions.
And is the first subscription electric toothbrush adapted by the American Dental
Association.
Excepted.
Sorry.
Now it's already eight 45 and I,
that happened.
Plus they're backed by a network of over 25,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy pressures.
Use Quip everyday.
Quip starts at just $25.
And if you go to get quip.com/bar right now,
you'll get the first refill pack for free with quip electronic toothbrush,
electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack for free.
At [inaudible] dot com Ge Tqi p.com/ [inaudible] spelled GE,
TQ.
uyp.com/bar.
All right,
I'll be back in a second.
Yeah.
Oh right.
I'm back.
The radio tour is over.
Let's finish up this podcast.
Oh look,
the last read.
Bodo don't do [inaudible] beyond ease.
Finished my radio tour.
Dodo.
Dodo beyond ease beyond these.
Get the boy shorts.
You whore.
Yay.
Come up your ad.
Spend over that table.
Oh,
frigging bang.
You're like,
I'm Clark Gable with my ginger mustachioed face.
Um,
from the frat gold race.
I'm really pasty.
All right.
Mandy's everybody.
You've heard me obsess over my [inaudible].
You've heard me talk about how they are softer than cotton and come with fun new
prints each month.
But I've got a big scoop for you.
That's the Scott.
What scoop?
I just literally fixed picture.
Just like you shit your pants.
Uh,
that I'm so excited to show you shit.
Yeah,
me undies.
Newbie undies.
What the shit trap door that I'm so excited to share with you all.
[inaudible] he's just gave them maps,
membership,
a massive upgrade.
All those dirty,
old,
whole ridden disgusting
underwear you've hung on onto.
It's time to throw all of that out and give you a top drawer.
The refresher it deserves.
Each month.
Me undies,
we'll release a new executive print that only members can get.
Can you imagine all this skid marked under where this is going to be thrown out
because of this promotion?
These could be collaborations with artists,
brands,
or other unique designs you are going to definitely want to have.
Members will also pay less for everything on [inaudible] website with special
member pricing.
That means if you want a second pair of undies,
a,
I don't know what the,
uh,
Braylin,
I don't know what that is.
Or lounge pants.
You'll pay less than anyone else.
The membership comes with no strings attached.
You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel it anytime.
You're going to love these Sundays.
They're the softest underwear you ever put on and they come with fun prints that
you can match with socks or a bright.
What the fuck is a Braille it?
Well,
here's a bro.
I gotta look this up right now.
[inaudible]
Hey,
by the way,
uh,
the show in season one on me,
TV of a 77 sunset strip.
I can't wait.
I missed the first couple,
but I got,
I got episode six.
You know what's crazy?
Is it,
oh,
is that bracelet
the,
how do you say it?
How do you say it?
What?
Say you,
Bro?
I'm so dumb.
There's no,
okay.
Pronuncia pronunciation acetate.
Here we go.
Come on.
Brad OLED
brelade brow outlet
brow led.
All right,
I got it.
All right.
Okay.
They come with fun prints that you can match with your socks or your brown lat.
They come with a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love them,
just send them back
for a full refund.
Me undies has a great offer for my listeners for the first time purchasers,
uh,
when you purchase any me undies,
you can get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on.
And who knows?
Maybe someday you can match them to your Brown.
Let,
um,
no,
I can't.
Well,
Hey,
yeah.
I said no ma.
Yeah,
Milan.
Uh,
all right.
So let's see here.
I did nine minutes than I did 13 minutes.
Now I've done four minutes.
Nine and three is 21 and four is 25.
I've got to be nothing in the five,
six minutes left.
Now the five,
Oh,
Billy glueless.
So anyways,
I have,
I haven't drank in like,
oh,
what is it here?
Uh,
33,
Larry,
Larry Legend.
33 days.
No booze.
Wow.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I have really had no intentions.
I'm going to drink one day next week celebrating with Joe to Rosetta Stone.
Rose his birthday on August six.
Make sure you give all twinkle toes a little shout out.
All right.
Make sure you get that little saloon whore.
A little tippy of fucking cowboy hat day.
He'd love to hear from you.
Uh,
Joe,
by the way,
is really an incredible inspirational speaker on a,
have you guys seen Joe de Roses?
Uh,
Instagram mean he has.
He's sitting there shirtless with his awful bodies.
Like he always goes,
what's up hard bodies?
Joe To Rosie here telling you that you don't have to be a slave to your diet.
I Dunno.
Just look up at Joe de Rosa or is it at Joe to Rosa comedy?
Just look up Joe de Rosa Instagram.
Maybe I can do it for you.
I'll make it easy for you because she's felt you're probably pretending to type
right now.
Acting as though you're working a Joe to Rosa Instagram.
He's on the gram.
Oh,
and I'm not connected to the fucking Internet course.
Why would I be,
why would I in this day and age be connected to the Internet?
It's just most of the free world is.
Most of the free world is right there connected to it.
They're connected.
They're connected to the know.
I don't,
let me type this in here.
Brow at all.
Right.
Joe To Rosa.
Instagram right away.
All right GRANDPA.
It's at Joe to Rosa comedy.
J.
O.
E d e
R.
O.
S.
A
comedy.
Um,
there you go.
Why don't,
why am I hyping his Goddamn Instagram page?
What does Joe to Rosa ever done for me?
Other bench other than being being a power for the last fucking 15 years.
Um,
all right.
What the what to talk about?
I was just promoting rough and rowdy by the way,
the cop versus the skateboarder.
That fight is actually,
that one's called pig versus punk.
So you get pride versus prejudice.
Pig Verse Punk,
Eh,
uh,
where could you go from there?
Palookaville [inaudible]
it'll boxer fight.
Say a politician.
That could be a good one.
They should have just sort of an,
uh,
an endless one foot with the letter P.
Huh?
You could have a,
somebody with a bladder problem.
Peer verse
poorer.
Go the bladder problem.
Fight somebody who's a economically,
uh,
in the Shit House.
I don't know.
Okay.
Maybe there's not an endless one.
I Dunno.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I'm just spit balling here people.
It's all I'm trying to do.
Just spit balling.
So anyways,
I got to,
uh,
I'm going to go see a nutritionist for the first time ever tomorrow and uh,
I'm going to get that taken care of.
I did the lat pull down machine 70 fucking pounds.
Gradually I'm putting it back together the way it really happens.
Not like on Dr Phil where he's like,
yeah,
all you need to stop,
pause,
trigger her in the face and like somebody who I would actually punch a woman to
face the fact that he said that like it's going to get rid of everything that he
saw as a child in that moment on Dr Phil Stout works.
That's going to be,
it's going to take that guy in an entire lifetime to stop punching women in the
face or shooting heroin or jacking off in public whenever the fuck it is he's
doing.
Right.
But not all Philly.
Philly makes it seem like he solves it right then in there with a little fucking
catch phrase is some bullshit.
That's why,
you know,
back in the day when I used to watch police academy and I would see private
hooks under the cute little black girl,
you know what I mean?
And she'd be all mousy,
like,
hey,
you hit that kick and the guy,
you got to get a scream.
And then in the end she'd get her nerve up and she jumped out of nowhere with a
gun out and she goes,
don't move dirt bag.
And then you'd see police academy to when she'd go back to being this little
mousy person again.
And you're like,
what the fuck?
Okay,
that's bad writing.
That's what I thought.
That's lazy.
You're going to have to do the exact same arc all the way to don't move dirt bag
again.
And I used to think that that was lazy writing,
but now having tried to,
to fix,
to control my temper,
no,
I'll flip out,
be like,
I don't want to do that again.
And then I'm fucking,
you know,
working on a,
working on a working on and I'm good for three weeks and then I,
I have a relapse.
You know,
private hooks is one of the most accurate characters ever,
ever written because you seeing somebody trying,
they have a breakthrough and you think,
is this it that I finally break through?
And then,
uh,
nope,
it was just a blip.
Now you're going back to being mousy again and she had to work on it through
like 1819 police academies and I don't know if she ever got there,
but I think we all could relate simply by the fact that she was just out there
trying.
There you go.
So that's nine minutes,
nine minutes and 13 minutes.
That's 31 minutes.
Jesus Christ.
People.
I think I'm done here.
I'm back up to regular volumes.
Tune into the red sox,
Yankees if you want to check that out.
Um,
but definitely this Sunday man,
make me look good.
Make it seem like I drove some traffic to this wonderful event.
Go to rough and rowdy brawl.com to watch pride verse prejudice pig first punk
and Cleveland Brown fans trying to do with the browns have never done on the
field,
which is beat something
from Pittsburgh.
Ah,
why did you have to be mean?
Because you know what?
It makes people listen.
All right.
Enjoy this music.
And then we'll have another half hour of greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast,
and the Thursday gone by from years ago or possibly last month.
I don't know how it works.
God bless you.
Have a great weekend and a two and then I'll be dressed in shabby.
I'll be in Youngstown for the first time ever.
And everybody else see you.
Rochester in New York on Saturday night with the Great Dean del Rey in the
opening slot.
All right,
God bless you.
And then United States of America.
Yeah.
So at the beginning of fucking $6 million man,
you know when that little fucking kite that he's fought flying,
why don't they ever show that fucking show in reruns?
That's one of the greatest goddamn shows ever.
Do you guys ever see that?
You have any idea how fucking huge it was when the $6 million man fought the $7
million man
and he punched his fucking face off his face came off
on television in like 1974 do you have any fucking idea?
Think about that.
Pre Internet,
pre cable,
pre any sort of special,
if you look how bad the graphics weren't,
Star Wars,
the judgements between frames,
all the tiny moving parts are minuscule but projected at the proper speed.
24 frames per second.
These individual movements will flow seamlessly together.
Actually models which can be carried in the palm of your hand.
Since like three,
four years before that Lee Majors Punch this dude who was the fucking bad guy in
everything.
Oh Man.
Do you remember the one where the $6 million man fight up fucked in the snow?
Yeah.
Fuck.
Okay.
Good.
As an expert and a French author [inaudible]
outside that mansion and they had everybody in slow motion and that black dude
jumped like 10 feet in the air was going to kick him.
He's going,
yeah.
Wow.
Flying through the fucking air.
Are you going to stand how sheltered I was as a kid.
I didn't even know who Bruce Lee was.
I don't even know what Kung Fu fighting was.
And I didn't realize that TV shows were ripping off,
you know,
uh,
enter the dragon and all that shit that people were flipping out about.
Cause I was just a little kid.
So I saw that shit.
I,
it was the most unbelievable thing ever.
He fought big foot.
He fought a black Bruce Lee and he fought the $7 million man and he punched his
fucking face off and tell them they just don't,
they don't make,
it's impossible to compete now that's just,
they've just done too many things.
You know.
It's Kinda like when you go to write a movie script,
you're like,
oh,
everything's been done.
And they act like all these guys back in the forties and 50s were brilliant.
It's like fuck you.
There was only like five movies were ever made.
How hard was it to be brilliant back then?
It's like inventing shit and eat in the 18 hundreds oh look,
it's a coat hanger.
You can hang your coat on it.
Holy Shit.
Let's put his name in the history books.
Everyone can fucking remember this for the rest of the time.
I don't even know what you could event.
You always great.
It's still inventing a simple shit.
Is that Billy Mays guy?
You know that Baird if fuck every night he just starts swab
Billy Mays.
I Billy made sure for the Jupiter Jack the most convenient hands free device for
any cell phone guaranteed.
That dude,
he doesn't even event the shit.
I think he invented like three things and then he's just got a sweat shop but
like smart fucking kids from Thailand and he just comes walking in.
I keep Barda myself on the iron.
Come up with some shit.
Then like three weeks later he's on TV.
Yeah.
Billy Mays.
Are you tired of burn their hair off your forearm or your art and your putting
down cause your third marriage didn't work out and you still have to date and
your fifties
hey dosing the fucking thing you stick in front of the iron that doesn't burn
your forearm but still irons the fuck.
Good shirt.
Um,
anyways,
Oh let me get,
let me get back to this thing.
Sorry.
Huh?
See like that.
There you go.
I wanted to stand up.
Mo gave you some fucking laughs.
Okay.
And his left eye.
What does his I do,
it's like a zoom lens on a camera.
A Zoom Lens.
Amazing.
It's like a bounce.
So anybody want watch 60 minutes.
This past week they did a,
they did this feature and that feature on mountain lions and all California is
the only state that has mountain lions just walking around
Los Angeles and its suburbs are home to 19 million people.
The only mega city in the world where mountain lions,
also known as cougars and Pumas live side by side with humans for 13 years.
The National Park Service has been studying the animal.
Uh,
I'm going to fuck this up in a,
in a park,
I guess maybe the size of like Griffith Park or Runyon Canyon or or whatever
those ones are out.
Uh,
out in the valley,
22 wanders the hills of Griffith Park,
a small enclave in Los Angeles,
frequented by hikers and visitors to the parks.
Famed Observatory.
I guess they have these fucking things.
And,
um,
so anyways,
I was watching it because a few of the places where I hike with my dog and this
thing has intermittently,
this does,
this group of fucking mountain lions has been around there.
But fortunately they try to avoid you,
I guess
a trail camera caught this one,
a stone's throw from the rooftops of suburbia
and these animals do their best to,
you know,
stay elusive and away from us,
um,
at least during the day if they're not fucking hungry.
But they showed this fucking,
uh,
these people,
these mountain lion,
right.
Okay.
They were having some work done.
So they had somebody going underneath the house into the crawl space of the
house and they will write up against this park.
And the guy went down there and he immediately came back up and he was fucking
like white as a ghost and they were like a dawn.
That is,
you know,
fucking white people trying to speak Spanish.
Right.
Oh eight.
Um,
is it French?
I don't know.
Um,
and a guy comes out of the fucking hall and was like,
yeah,
man,
I fucking,
uh,
there's a mount line down there.
I just came faced tonight.
Get outta here.
You're shy,
I guess.
And they will like,
he's like,
yeah,
it's fucking down there.
And,
and so anyways,
they interviewed this fucking La couple and they had the quintessential fucking
la couple.
Okay.
A mountain lion in your house,
Bro.
And Shy.
He said that on the mountain lion.
He goes,
yeah,
man.
Face to face,
eye to eye to eye with me.
And he music terrified.
You know what I mean?
He looks like the leading man of a B movie,
right?
She's got like bleach blonde hair.
She's
wearing,
fuck me pumps.
She's on 60 minutes.
Where in fuck me pumps.
It's fucking hilarious.
Walking around,
done up to the nines.
And uh,
I actually,
uh,
it was pretty cool.
I was trying to figure out where the house was.
I Google mapped it and I think I was able to find it,
but I'm a fuck.
The state is so fucking insane with the droughts,
the fires,
the rattlesnakes,
the coyotes,
the mountain lions.
You know what everybody's saying?
This place is so phony and so plastic.
Well,
you know,
it can get,
uh,
that can all go away pretty damn quick with the wildlife.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
August 2nd,
2010.
Oh my God.
Martha,
can you believe it?
It's already August.
Could you believe it Martha?
Actually,
I can't Karen,
because it was just July in my entire life.
August has come after July,
so yes,
I can believe that it's August 2nd.
Why do you have to do that?
Do what that,
you know,
why can't you just,
have frivolous conversation?
Why do you have to be,
why do you have to be such a cunt?
No,
I'm sorry.
Well that's what's your big,
um,
anyway.
Oh,
O g h.
Oh my God.
What the fuck did I do last night?
I was going to do the podcast last night.
That was the plan.
Boys and girls,
ladies and gentlemen,
children of all ages.
I was going to do the podcast last night,
I was going to upload this motherfucker a midnight my time,
you know,
for all my friends out there and the fucking,
uh,
Great Britain out there in Ireland and Iceland,
you know,
that'd be like eight o'clock in the morning for you.
Right?
You get up,
you people in Iceland throwing down some hay for your fucking Jakks,
taking out your pan flute,
skipping around,
looking for the gold.
He's not what you do out there.
Yeah,
well that's what I think it though.
Cause I took geography and America.
Yeah.
So you know what's up,
Holla and how's your windmills?
Now you're clicking your fucking wooden shoes together.
That's my version.
That's my version of hall.
And they don't even have cell phones out.
Their cell phones is still using pitchforks to get their point across.
Um,
that didn't even make sense.
But what did I do instead?
You know,
this is the classic life of the loser.
All right?
And if you are a loser,
not saying you are,
okay.
Hypothetically,
if you are a loser,
you're going to recognize this pattern.
Okay?
And this is the pattern of the loser.
You'll see the loser knows what he or she is supposed to do and the and,
and then you never do it,
and that is a pattern of a loser.
All right?
Did they make any fucking sense?
It started like I was gonna make this huge fucking point and then my headache
really just kicked in there,
but let's,
let's try it.
Let's try to put the wheels back on the cart here.
All right.
Just like those people.
I'm out there in Finland right now
and all the people down and fucking Australia wrestling those poisonous snakes
as the aborigines fucking sit there with that.
That white God damn tooth sticking through their nose.
You know that shark tooth that Greg Brady had around his fucking neck when he
was going to be the next Johnny Bravo
just sitting there fucking staring at me.
They're aborigine,
man.
You think I need that shit?
You think?
You think I'm the one who kicked you off your fucking land?
I'm a Goddamn indentured servant to the fucking banks.
They're half naked aborigine dude.
All right.
To Stop fucking staring at me.
With Your Thong.
You're fucking sad face.
All right.
I didn't create plastics.
I'm just dealing with it.
Why don't you show me how to fucking join whatever it is your thinking about
rather than fucking judging me.
And by the way,
could you help me with this fucking snake over here?
Um,
anyways,
this is what the loser does.
Um,
yeah.
I was gonna.
I was,
I was going to do x,
Y and z button stand.
I did fucking d and F
fucking idiot.
Instead of knowing that God damn podcast,
I went out and I drank last night.
Oh Gee,
I wish I had two whiskeys and to Miller high life.
Why did I have Miller high life?
You know what?
Cause the bottle look good.
I like the way the bottle look.
It's one of those nights there's a shiny looking bottle.
I like that.
I'm going to have that.
I'm going to block out those fucking awful Miller highlife commercials.
I hated those commercials.
That fucking plumber with his greasy fingers picking up that deviled egg.
It's like,
are you trying to stay at Budweiser?
Right.
These fucking heads.
All right.
This is just anger,
just of frustration at myself.
I don't know why I did the things I did last night.
I shot pool,
you know,
like I'm fucking Willie Mosconi.
You know that's it.
Yeah.
We as a man,
you just walk up to a pool table even though you know you suck and you just
thinking it'd be like,
you know,
seven ball corner pocket and it's going to fucking go right in and never goes
in.
You know,
just like your life.
You think it's on target.
It think it's heading right towards your way,
where you want it to go.
And Bam bounces off the fucking wall and next thing you know,
it's all the way on the other side of the fucking table.
This is ridiculous.
I shouldn't be doing this right now.
I resent.
I'm resenting.
I'm blaming you guys.
I'm fucking blaming you.
Sitting in your God damn cubicles.
What do you think about that?
What did he do?
He can't fucking do anything about it.
What do you do?
You're going to send me fucking emails complaining.
Yeah.
Well I don't give a shit.
I don't fucking,
I mean,
had breakfast,
Jeff sitting in my pajamas doing that thing.
When you're hung over,
you know,
we just sort of rub your feet together,
trying to give yourself some sort of soothing feelings on the other.
Render your body because your fucking head is throbbing so much.
Well,
maybe I can offset the headache with a soothing feeling between my footies and
of course it's not working.
Oh Fuck Jesus Christ.
Two whiskeys and two bears.
I feel like I fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
Like,
I dunno what,
like I had a fight in the parking lot and I lost.
And last thing I remember with somebody grabbing my big ears and bouncing my
head off the asphalt as I'm growing,
I a writer,
right?
You won,
you won,
and then you just slip off into a dream.
Ooh.
Um,
you know,
it's weird.
I woke up whenever I wake up,
hung over.
Um,
you know,
one of the first things I do is I just start cursing out the woman in my life.
You know,
this is my remedy.
Forgetting over a hangover.
You know,
you wake up and you see him,
you know,
and you're trying to get the fucking,
yeah,
that goddamn cement out of your eyes.
He's,
you're trying to open them up.
And of course,
because you're hung over and you want to be alone,
the vibe you're putting out is you want to be alone.
What happens?
You create,
you attract what you fucking fear.
Not only another human being right in your goddamn face,
it's gotta be a female.
Okay?
And God knows,
can they ever stop running their yaps.
It's like even when they don't have something to say,
they're going to fucking talk because as much as they talk a good game,
I'm an independent woman and I got my money,
motherfucker,
all that shit.
At the end of the day,
all these broads are afraid of the same thing.
They're afraid of silence.
That's what it is.
You know that when you watch one of those goddamn shows or in my life,
you walk by and your girls watch and one of those goddamn shows Wa and why am I
bringing my voice down?
Like she's still in the apartment?
She,
but you know what?
He just want to bring my voice down here.
This is,
I'm either talking about the Illuminati or I'm talking about these fucking
bitches.
Um,
this is all hangover talk here.
So,
oh fuck all you guys,
if you're taking this seriously.
All right.
Rule number one,
or is it number two at this point?
You don't fucking take the podcast seriously.
Okay.
All you girls out there,
you get your panties in a bunch.
[inaudible] why does he make fun of man?
Well,
it is,
it balance it out because that's life sweetheart.
And Life isn't fair.
Why don't you go listen to one of those fucking 20 Twat podcast with the fucking
broad over there running hurt God damn.
Yet between her cleavage.
Huh?
Why don't you go do that sister Pam would get tampons in your purse just in
case.
Whew.
I am in a mood.
Um,
yeah,
so I'm sitting there and I got,
they're afraid of silence.
Stay on target.
They are,
they're afraid of silence and that's why they talk about nothing.
Oh,
that's what I was trying to say.
You walk by the TB and your girlfriend's sitting there,
right?
She do.
You know,
sitting there on the couch right in the couch.
Sidesaddle he now they sit,
leaned up against the arm with their legs to the side rubbing if footies
together that a peaking out of the Afghan.
What?
I liked this show.
You Watch your shows.
Do I say anything when you're watching your shows?
I joke.
So why didn't you extent shot up?
So you know,
you walked by the fucking TV,
you walked by the Goddamn TV and what and what is it?
What is on the TV?
You know what?
I don't even remember.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Oh yeah,
they're just running their yaps.
Oh,
I got it.
Hey,
we go.
I'm hooked.
Backed up to it.
Then we go,
there was a little awkward.
This,
they're like,
you ever see when a,
when a jet tries to refuel in mid flight,
you know,
and that Shark Dick is hanging down.
I know what a shark Dick looks like.
What do think about that?
Is that scandalous enough to get on TMZ and my low level of notoriety?
I do.
I was watching this fucking a nature show and these fucking creepy humans cause
that's what we are pull is great white shark out of the fucking sea.
And the sharks laying there like,
I can't fucking breathe over here.
Right?
And they got this little garden hose going into his mouth and it seemed the
sharks looking like,
really this is the same as in he isn't fucking hailing a mouthful of ocean.
You little fucking true value hardware garden hose that you got my fucking
mouth.
What are they doing?
Get away from my Dick please.
And they literally reached down and between a couple of faults,
they pull out this shark cock,
which amazingly enough looks just like the fucking,
uh,
that,
that tube that they refuel in the air for with,
or whatever the fucking preposition is that a preposition.
I don't fucking know.
Trying to complete a sentence over here and that's what it looks like.
All right,
there you go.
That portion was dedicated to all our troops over there in Afghanistan and then,
uh,
Tuscaloosa,
um,
you know,
it's a weird thing.
I was sitting in the airport.
I'm going to get back to the broads.
I'm going to give them a break right now.
Okay.
I tried,
I tried to knock them out in that round and now I'm fucking winded.
I'm taking a round off his debts,
starting to score points.
I'm just giving them,
I'm just giving them hope.
Taking a round off,
but I'm coming out with the next one.
I'm putting a glove in their face like Larry Holmes and I'm coming with the
overhand right.
My favorite fucking thing in boxing.
Um,
God,
what was I just talking about?
I was talking about Shark Dicks.
I'm gonna have to shark dicks.
Oh,
I know.
I'm in the airport.
All right.
Can,
this is just going to be all momentum.
I'm going to just try to not stop talking for 50 minutes because when I stopped
talking,
the throbbing in my head is actually audible.
All right.
Slow it down,
Bill.
Let's take it down a little bit.
A little fucking some fucking smooth jazz here.
All right,
so I'm sitting in the fucking airport.
This was an awkward thing,
right?
Uh,
at least troops came walking by and these people spontaneously started to
applaud,
you know,
and I didn't know what to do.
Do I join in?
It just didn't seem right.
But then you don't want to not fucking show your appreciation,
but applause just seems weird.
It just seemed weird and I was trying to put myself in their fucking position.
Like,
you know,
you just came out of Fallujah,
did what you had to do over there,
and then you get fucking however it works.
Next thing you know,
you're on jet blue and you land at an airport and there's a soccer mom.
Woo.
Good game.
You know,
I don't know what to do.
Definitely appreciate them.
But so that's for the troops out there.
Do you want applause in the airport or is it fucking weird?
You know,
cause we don't want to do that shit that happened to the troops when they came
back from Vietnam and all those fucking hippies were like,
hey man,
that wasn't cool when you burn down,
that Dude's hut me and we don't want to do that,
but I don't want to have an overcorrection,
you know,
what do you like Dan [inaudible] bed is that fucking song.
They play it up.
I'm trying to think of like college football songs,
you know,
here come the troops,
but I'm an APP bomp bomp Bam.
And on and on.
And in order to want to go,
he had a Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
You don't want to go like two high energy.
There's gotta be a happy medium
between sitting there being like,
oh,
the leaves are brown.
And then sitting there,
you know,
applauding like somebody just sank a putt.
It just didn't seem right.
All right.
So anyway,
so you walked by the TV and there's the,
in the broad's always.
They're always talking about how much more,
uh,
I guess,
how much,
what better communicators,
females are,
which I've probably proven of the last fucking 14 minutes of this podcast.
Um,
and now he did.
Oh,
if a woman actually says 20,000 more words a day,
then a guy does.
Do you realize that yet?
Do you think?
I didn't notice.
I thought it was 40,000 more.
Okay.
And let me tell you something.
They're fucking a sinkhole.
We
just,
because you're saying more words doesn't mean you're saying anything.
All right.
You basically filler your way through silence with your girlfriend because both
of you are sitting there.
Yeah.
Afraid that if you stop talking,
you're going to hear the sound of your boob sagging.
All right.
Oh yeah.
Well,
that's what I think it is in my own fucking ignorance.
All right,
let's get on with the podcast here.
People,
I'm sorry.
I had to,
I had to do a little cardio there just to get myself through the first 15
minutes,
you know,
now I can fucking chill.
So I woke up,
hung over today,
obviously,
and I'm attack and the broads because I'm hung over and not for the most part,
I don't like him.
Um,
I like to look at them.
I liked to come over and stick my dick in him,
you know,
but after that,
it's like,
why don't you get out in the kitchen and make me one of them fucking blog ms
sandwiches when she just fucking love to be that guy,
you know?
Just find some little fucking mouse of a woman to live with.
Just blame your entire afternoon on her.
Where the fuck is a fucking room up?
Oh,
you had it last.
What the fuck did you say?
I guess it was my fault.
This is terrible.
This isn't even comedy anymore.
This is just me.
So I woke up this morning,
hung over as I've mentioned 98 times.
And for some reason I woke up and uh,
this song was in my head.
I just woke up.
But this was the song that was in my head right here,
hung over off my ass.
And all of a sudden,
I just hear Elvis,
Joel,
shake me your be hitch.
Ooh,
that's one of the great fucking songs by Elvis Presley and a,
when you really listen to the lyrics,
um,
it's,
he's a fucking psycho.
He stock in this broad,
how they in the kitchen,
Holly in the whole,
let me go on to do your head a good at
because,
well,
and saw the kitchen kitchen in the kisses starts a team of wild horses couldn't
pull us apart.
He's singing about rape everybody,
but he gets that.
Oh,
and it's,
and it just smooths it all out.
And that's why he was the king.
Only the king can make rape seem,
uh,
like it's,
it's the right thing to do for both parties.
Let's just be clear on that for both parties.
All right,
let's get on with the podcast.
Okay.
I,
I fucking love that song and I really do.
And I was working the Orleans and,
and a casino with Tom Papa in the marriage.
Refs,
Tom Papa.
Um,
I was coming out on stage like that and I felt love for half a second.
I felt like 1 million bucks.
If I have a fucking second.
Can you believe it's August?
Um,
all right.
So let's get on with the podcast.
Last week,
ladies and Gentlemen,
I had the pleasure of performing on the David Letterman show.
And,
uh,
most of you went out,
you watched it and you all sent me wonderful emails about it and I would read
you the wonderful emails,
but they're not funny,
but you are in luck.
You know what ones are funny?
The ones where people did not like my performance.
So let's read a couple of those.
Shall We?
All right now my fucking nose is running.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
I did a little coke last night.
Everybody.
No,
never had the balls.
Never had the balls to mess with that shit.
Okay?
Uh,
this is a,
this is somebody and I was always,
um,
uh,
for those of you whenever I read my hate mail,
um,
both of these,
the two hate mail emails that I would be reading,
uh,
this morning,
all of a sudden I sound like right now like a teacher teaching a really boring
class.
You know that you're in,
you know,
first class of that semester,
right?
You finally got yourself a little bit of Poon Tang.
You're happy.
You floating around,
everything's going to be great.
You're thinking,
okay,
let's see all my teachers are going to be,
and then that do.
She comes out.
Welcome
to meteorology in the media.
My name is mister cunt face and Mr [inaudible] face when I'm in third grade,
I'm sorry,
I'm hung over.
I couldn't come up with my name is Mr Magilla Kati.
Over the course of the next three months,
we're going to be delving into the water for all the meteorology in the media.
You will be required to write to 27 page papers
on cirrus clouds.
It lived the codas.
Okay,
so cirrus clouds were first discovered.
Yeah,
the 1600 risk by bad weather.
They laugh and they picks up the fucking marker.
He's writing across that fucking bored.
Yeah,
so your Makkah is Lars yet the third
at first,
before I said mark is a Catholic at the or,
they thought the cirrus clouds.
We're actually the God's sake that your wife was account.
I get nothing.
What's the breathing annoying it was supposed to be.
Um,
all right,
let's read the hate mail here.
So what happens with all of all of my hate mail is when people don't like my act
is he can't just write me evidently and just say that you don't like my act.
You don't appreciate what it is that I do on the stage.
What you have to do first is you have to establish what an incredible sense of
fucking humor you have and how open you are to all different forms of humor.
You know,
it's that classic thing like those douchebags on Youtube.
Obama's a fucking idiot and I'm a Democrat,
right?
So then we can be like,
wow,
this guy is left and even he doesn't like this lefty guy.
So this is what they do.
All right,
so here.
So these both these emails follow to a Goddamn fucking t did the motherfucking u
and V,
um,
they follow it here.
They follow that pattern bill.
Just read the fucking thing.
Okay,
here we go.
All right.
Hi there.
How this one starts starts off.
Nice enough.
Hi there.
I've been a fan for a while.
You seem to have a unique take on things.
Look at this,
Huh?
Pat me on the head but me sniffer hand making me nice and fucking relax.
I loved your bit about the muffins and the mass vehicular murder.
Yeah,
so there you go.
She just showed how we,
it just,
her sense of humor spans the globe
whether I'm attacking food are actually running over human beings on the
sidewalk.
She finds it all funny though.
And here's the rub though.
As a stay at home mom,
I now completely despise you.
I did this bit about being a stay at home mom.
Um,
so anyways,
she says the hardest part about being a stay at home mom is being respect is
being disrespected by everyone.
I now hope the worst for you,
despite what funny acts you may think up in the future.
You are a jerk and deserve the worst that life has to offer.
Okay.
I don't fuck it.
I don't,
I don't understand like this is the classic fucking person where everything is
until it comes around to some shit in her life.
And I make some fun is some shit that she's doing,
being a stay at home mom.
And now all of a sudden she goes from being a fan of mine to now I am a jerk and
deserve the worst that life has to offer.
That's,
that's a fucking hard courts that you deserve.
The worst that life has to offer.
So what?
I'm going to get leprosy and uh,
be constipated all at the same time and fucking survive a plane crash,
but not in a good way,
you know?
Anyways,
I don't fucking know.
Rarely you're going to take it to that level.
So I wrote her back and I said,
a sweetheart,
Oprah Winfrey called your job the toughest job on the planet,
on national television and got an applause break of approval.
How much more respect do you need?
I think that's a great point.
If I can step outside the email,
break the fucking fourth wall.
Is that what it is?
The third wall?
I never knew what the fuck it was.
Huh?
Oprah Winfrey's on TV saying you have the toughest job on the planet and
everybody claps.
All right.
Did she say being a standup comedian is the toughest job on the planet.
You think you know what it's like to be fucking disrespected.
You Apron wearing sheltered son of a bitch.
Huh?
You want to talk about being disrespected?
Look at fucking comedians.
Anytime they show a comedian in a movie.
Is it a Chris Rock level comic?
It never is.
It's the fucking hack with the lampshade on his head going Wakawaka right.
Didn't the fucking comedian get shot in his gut during Scarface?
Ah,
did a fucking stay at home.
Mom gets shot in the fucking stomach with that Mr. Potato head mask on her face
during that show.
No.
You know why?
Cause she was at home taking care of the fucking kids
at Jesus Christ.
I'm just gonna read the rest of this email.
That didn't even fucking make sense.
It started off funny and then it just went right off the rails like a Prius that
you can't fucking stop.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
she says,
so I wrote,
I wrote how much more respect do you need?
And then I said,
meanwhile,
there are children working in sweat shops.
Would you rather be a stay at home mom or an eight year old sewing Adidas
together for 16 hours a day.
I came up with another great example that I,
I wish I had used on TV.
How about how about you work on one of those fucking oil rigs?
Like those poor bastards who worked for BP?
Then all of a sudden out of nowhere the fucking thing explodes.
You standing on a metal structure in the middle of the goddamn ocean and next
thing you know blows up,
probably blew out both your eardrums.
He had deaf now and you're on fire.
All right?
And your only option is either burning to death or jumping off of basically the
equivalent of the top of a brownstone
trying to enter the water without doing the world's biggest flaming belly flop,
right?
You land in the water,
second and third degree burns in salt water,
alright,
pus and blood is oozing into the water and now all you can do is pray to God
that the coast guard gets there before is see as sharks eat you alive.
All right?
You want to do that or you want to watch Bob the builder for the 800 time
lighten up.
And then I wrote,
Oh,
and don't despise or hope the worst for me.
That causes premature aging hugs.
I know that was kind of mean to say,
but you know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
here's another one.
Once again,
we have to establish credibility at the top of the email.
Are you guys ready for the credibility to be established?
Jesus Christ,
I know I am.
Here we go.
Ah,
Bill,
I am never appalled or capital letters offended by comedy that I see in here.
All capitals,
his sentence.
I have a great sense of humor.
Wow.
This is unbelievable.
Isn't that amazing?
Podcast listeners,
this person is never appalled or offended by comedy that she sees or hears.
She has a great sense of humor.
She has such a great sense of humor.
People that she had to yell at at me and emails.
All right,
so this no way she had a problem with my act,
right?
Let's read the rest of the email,
however,
oh gee,
your appearance on the David Letterman show that I just watched,
just put down women and motherhood to an extent that is just downright
unbelievable.
Dot Dot,
dot.
Now she's going to yell again and tasteless.
Now she yells for the rest of this email,
but I'm going to spare you guys.
All right.
I'm going to read it and soothing tones,
but she's screaming the entire time.
That's what I'm guessing because it's all capital letters.
Um,
this is what she says.
I challenge you to be a single parent and raise a child and work and attend
college alone without any help just in case you don't know what being a single
parent mates.
All right?
Um,
you have no idea how hard it really is.
I am disgusted with your act and will not ever buy any of your DVDs,
et Cetera.
For the first time in my life,
I am disgusted with comedy.
Your comedy,
that is like a,
she starts speaking like in film nor,
and I'm disgusted with his comedy.
Y'All comedy that is,
see,
Eh,
23.
Skidoo.
All right.
Your Act touched on many topics that you were disgraceful and very unappealing.
And then she got so mad she stopped writing sentences.
Um,
first of all,
sweetheart,
I wasn't making fun of a single,
uh,
single,
parents that was making fun of single parents.
Nobody would laugh.
I was talking about stay at home moms.
All right?
You don't remember that line hanging out all day making grilled cheese
sandwiches.
You given a puppet show,
you dress like a dragon and then some other adult comes home and gives you
money.
You like a big kid.
That's some other dove coming home,
giving you money is your fucking husband.
You dumped broad.
Do I gotta fucking spell it out to you?
So I just wrote her back.
I just said I wasn't talking about single moms.
I was talking about stay at home moms.
You weren't listening.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alyssa.
I'm not going to do the show anymore.
If I have to put up with this.
I'm just kidding.
I love these fucking hate mail things and that's all I got.
I got,
I got to to uh,
bad emails and then I had one guy who wrote like a five page dissertation on uh,
on the shirt I was wearing under my suit or something like that.
And uh,
then I just went home a phobic with him.
I just wrote a,
that's one of the gay ass emails I've ever received.
Uh,
thanks for the fashion advice.
And then he wrote back trying to act as if I got a bunch of emails from guys
telling me to wear a carnation in my front pocket or whatever the fuck he was
saying.
And he wrote this big long fucking four page email and then I just hit him with,
come on sweetie,
don't be like that.
And then it ended it.
I got,
I got a lot of,
a little weird emails this week.
Somebody saw date night and said,
I need to be more choosy.
When I picked my roles,
which I thought was fucking hilarious.
Like someone who has eight lines in a movie is actually getting offers around
town.
We got to get this guy.
The way of telling you,
the way he stands next to other people talking in the film is incredible.
He is the best at it.
You know,
I got to be more choosy with,
with a fucking,
yeah.
Evidently because I wasn't doing stand up in the movie date night.
Like the role of my character was the straight man and the more the straight or
I played it,
the more opportunity for the other person to be funny in the seed.
That's your fucking job,
you know?
And I did the job and if I think that wasn't the job that I was supposed to do,
I would think that the director might have said something.
And just because I'm a fucking comedian doesn't mean I'm going to walk around,
you know,
with a lampshade on my fucking head.
Okay.
I'd love to be in a bad ass fucking movie.
What do you think I want to do?
You know,
you think I want to be in raising Arizona part to actually,
that would,
but uh,
I'd also like to be in a,
they can never make a movie as good as a good fellas.
I'd love to do some shit like that.
Play a fucking psycho.
Put the lotion in the bucket,
but wouldn't want to do that shit.
Alright.
You dumped.
Fuck am I,
I don't need to be more choosy about my roles.
I need to take anything anybody gives me.
Yeah.
Fucking shot that movie a year ago.
I haven't done another one.
Is that choosing enough for you?
Not Been.
I've gone.
It's not like I'm not trying.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's plow ahead here.
Let's get on with the,
what else do we got going on?
Oh,
by the way,
if I want to thank everybody.
Seriously,
I was just fucking around there with the,
uh,
the letter stuff.
I had an unbelievably great time and,
uh,
that was my best Letterman if I do say so myself.
I finally figured out the pacing that I have to go on TV.
And uh,
what I always used to try to do is I used to try to go comedy club speed,
but TV audiences for some reason laugh and clap a lot more.
And then I would,
I would try to do was plow through the applause and get the tag of the joke in
there.
And uh,
I dunno,
it's like a whole different animal.
You got to figure out what do you do when they're applauding,
you know,
why did the chicken cross road to get the US side?
Woo Woo.
Maybe that's why I didn't applaud when the troops came by because I thought that
they would feel as awkward as I do when you're just standing there going,
okay,
thank you.
Yes,
I know that was the greatest joke in the history of the world.
I am tremendous.
Where do you get alone of this one?
Um,
all right,
let's read some that's reached some,
uh,
oh,
and by the way,
later on that night,
um,
in celebration,
I had the most ridiculous fucking weekend,
um,
that an adult can have.
And part of most of his,
because,
uh,
you know,
I chose what I wanted to do in life was exactly what I wanted to do.
And secondly,
I'm not married and I don't have any fucking kids,
so I don't have any responsibility.
Hence,
I,
uh,
I get to live the life of a,
a gay guy.
You mean notice how happy fucking gay men are?
You know why that is is because they got the fucking double whammy.
They're a fucking man.
So they can earn way more an hour than the fucking broads over there and then
they don't have any God damn kids.
So once you get around 40,
if you've done great and your,
your career,
you have all this disposable income,
you know,
and the only way to kill the voices in your head that you should add a fucking
kid by now is to go out and do frivolous bullshit to fill up the free time.
And that's what I've been doing.
So I actually,
this weekend,
um,
one of the things I got to do this past weekend is so fucking unbelievable.
I can't even tell you how I even went down,
but I did take video of it.
And if you want to watch the video,
you can only go one place everybody.
And that's the M podcast.com.
Huh?
You like that?
Look at that and exclusive Monday morning podcast video that will only be shown
on the [inaudible] podcast.com of course until some douchebag takes it and puts
it up on Youtube.
So go to the MLM,
podcast.com and a watch a video of something that I got to do.
And uh,
I don't even,
I can't even begin to tell you how that whole fucking thing went down and how I
got to do it,
but,
uh,
was one of the great things I got to do in life.
So I got to do that,
which I won't be telling you because I'm trying to become a smarter businessman
here.
All right.
The only way you should hit pause right now and go to the FM podcast right now,
if you're not following along anyways.
Um,
I got to do that unbelievable activity.
And then,
uh,
what did I do?
I did Letterman on Monday and then Monday night I went down to the bitter end
and I watched that fucking amazing guy,
Oz.
Noy this guitarist,
if you ever get a chance,
have you ever in a New York one Monday a night,
this guy,
Oz noy goes down and he,
I don't know,
I can't even describe what the fuck it is.
He does.
Very,
very unique guitarist and he,
uh,
I don't mean you got to see him live.
You have to fucking see him live.
His youtube videos do not do him justice.
You got to go down and see him live and um,
and he's always playing with these top notch musicians.
He had a will leave from the Letterman band was there.
Steve Ferrone from the average white band actually went out and got a fucking
picture with them and Shit,
uh,
from the average white band and now Tom petty and he's played with a zillion
other people.
One of my drumming heroes got to meet him that fucking night.
And,
uh,
the guy on keyboards is one of the original guys from the e street band,
but I'm not into the e street band.
But this guy was the shit and I just watched these fucking unbelievable
musicians and sat in the crowd.
These guys was so fucking good that actually had the comforting thought that,
you know what robots will never take over fully.
Robots will never fully fucking take over because they'll never be able to do
what I just fucking saw.
I mean when he,
you're gonna write a program for passion,
God know some fucking egg head with no passion is probably figuring that shit
out.
Figuring out how to make a robot sweat.
Will it plays fucking guitar.
That'll be,
that'll be the big fucking breakthrough.
That's why drum machines never fully took over cause it's just somebody
programming the shit,
you know?
It's not a human being playing it.
Right.
Is that where,
I don't know.
I'm too fucking hung over and actually have a fucking a fucking touching moment
here in the podcast all a couple of weeks ago,
I told you guys how to dump,
how to get out of a fucking relationship.
All right.
Um,
and if you ever want to learn how to not get into a relationship,
go download a Andrew dice Clay's live album at Dangerfield that the,
uh,
the day the laughter died.
And one of my favorite bits of all time that he does is a,
I think it's called hot and how to not get into a relationship.
So if you don't even want to deal with how to get out of relationship,
listened to dice Clay's bit on how to not get into,
into a relationship and a,
but then if you fuck up and you get into one,
listen to my podcast from a couple of weeks ago and I'll,
I'll give you the blueprint on how to get out.
All right?
So anyway,
so this brought up the whole getting dumped
and people have been sending me emails about getting dumped or breaking up and
the awkwardness and all that type of shit.
He's some great stories.
Here's one for you getting dump a bill.
How's listening last week and wanted to tell you about the worst way I was
dumped.
Uh,
when I was in high school,
I had a friend who was a girl and I was in love with her in a pathetic,
never getting laid way while she was banging half the football team.
Oh Dude.
That's like that movie last,
uh,
last American virgin.
Right then I already used that reference on the podcast.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm hung over anyways.
I,
after high school,
graduate graduation,
we started dating even though we went to different colleges.
Seven hours apart,
um,
over.
Yeah.
I love how she starts dating you then because the football team left her and
went to 47 different colleges,
so she just needed a dick to ride.
Um,
over fall break I went to visit her and stayed at her place for the weekend.
On the last night at midnight,
she told me she was seeing someone else and then expected me to stay at her
house that night.
Oh,
what a cunt.
Um,
I got up and pack my shit.
And as I was about to leave,
I did my best Brando impression to let her know how she,
how she fucked up.
Um,
and as I started to go out the door after making my dramatic statement,
she said,
don't you need your keys?
Okay.
Oh,
this poor bastard.
He goes,
I forgot my keys on the table all the way across the room.
So I had to walk all the way across,
back the back,
across the room in shame to grab my keys and then drove seven hours back to
college in the middle of a,
in the middle of the night.
Dude,
let me tell you something.
You got,
you got half a victory there.
Um,
because you did leave and you know,
and you did,
you had the ability to walk all the way across the room to get your keys.
And at no point during that long fucking did you break down in tears.
You didn't.
All right,
don't you need your keys?
Ah,
ah,
that's fucking brutal.
That's like,
that's like mean.
Yeah.
Because you know what she thought,
I guess that you were going to stay there for the night.
So I guess she went mean there.
Don't you need your keys?
Obviously you need your keys.
If she was trying to let you down easy when she'd be like,
mmm,
be forgot your keys here and just would have the decency to look down at the
floor.
Don't you need your keys
now?
This is what I want to know from you.
And that's seven hours.
Drive back.
How many different snappy comebacks did you come with for?
Don't you need your keys?
I bet you were so fucking distraught.
They didn't even make sense.
Don't you need your keys?
Don't you need,
you can't write.
That doesn't even make sense.
But you know,
it's something you'd say.
Aww,
you poor bastard.
Whatever.
You know what the good news is?
She probably has three kids right now.
Her body's looking like she's standing in a fun house mirror and she probably
has some sort of fucking STD.
So,
you know,
there you go sir.
It all worked out in the end,
didn't it?
All right.
Uh,
bad covers.
This is from back in the day we talking about,
um,
when,
when an artist comes around like a lady Gaga,
you know,
when she comes around and she wraps herself in toilet paper and holds a fucking
dildo and everybody's like,
she's thinking a fashion thing,
but she shocking Middle America,
uh,
holding like a black baby while playing chess.
Is there anything worse than that?
Paint by numbers.
Shock,
you know,
and then,
then the fucking douchebags who cover it,
just stand right in line.
She's pushing boundaries.
She's rejecting what it is to be a woman.
Oh God,
shut up.
She's wearing a silly outfit.
Isn't that what she's doing
as a fan?
Blowing on her twat hanging off her belt buckle.
And then I'm supposed to sit there and be like,
I can't even process this.
This is cutting edge art.
I mean,
what is she really doing?
Oh,
good phase.
Oh my God,
I can't handle it.
This is like what Jimmy Hendrix came out.
No,
it isn't.
There's like when Cindy Lopper came up,
she braided half her fucking head,
right?
And dance down the street with their fucking shoulders going up and down,
yelling at Captain Lou Albano.
It's,
it's kind of on level.
I remember when Cindy Lopper did that shit and then she didn't do anything.
And next thing you know,
she's on,
she's on that fucking,
uh,
who wants to be a CEO getting fired by that guy who I don't even think has any
money or any Donald Trump fans out there.
I don't think that guy is rich.
I really don't.
I don't,
I don't buy it.
If this guy is such,
if he's so fucking rich and has all these goddamn businesses,
how does he have time to do a reality show and in critique,
who's better at running a lemonade stand?
Cindy Lopper or Bret Michaels is,
is that what it,
what a fucking a
fucking whatever the hell he is.
What do you,
what do you call a guy like that?
He's,
he's,
he's a,
uh,
a conglomerate,
a media conglomerate.
What the fuck is he called?
A A,
I can't think of the word.
I'm too fucking hung over.
It's not like one of those ingenue names.
And I know it's not that way.
I know what that,
that's not what it is.
Ingenue means you're a,
you're a good looking core core good looking whore.
Who some day
my brain is so fucked right now.
I just combined good looking in horror and she's a good,
she's a Gore Al Gore Al Gore,
who is a bitchier fucking body.
Al Gore or fucking Bill Clinton.
Both of them,
the big mother and hips sachet and around the White House with their fucking
suits on Eaton Stouffer fucking pies.
Um,
I am so off to track right now.
we're talking about bad covers.
No,
I'm,
this is,
this is what I really believe about Donald Trump for all his fucking Trump
water.
Trump tower,
Trump casino,
Trump helicopter.
Trump toenail clippers.
I don't think that that guy,
if you gave him fucking,
if you gave him 12 hours,
I don't think that he could come up with more than 6,500 bucks in cash.
I think he's just completely leveraged out.
But his projects are so big.
He's like the banks like he,
he's too big to fail.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck am I talking about?
Where the hell am I?
Let's get back to bed covers.
All right.
Bad covers.
Here's one for you.
Uh,
Madonna when she did a American pie,
um,
yeah,
that song kind of sucked to begin with.
And then,
um,
just in case you didn't realize it sucked,
Madonna came in and proved it.
Yes.
This song did suck.
Now even if you completely switch it up and put that club beat underneath it,
it's still gonna fucking suck of Jesus.
I'm just running on a momentum,
you know?
Did I really just do a lady Gaga impression?
I'll fuck you.
You enjoyed it.
You know,
you do a podcast hung over.
I want to see how good you do.
Yeah,
I didn't think so.
I didn't fucking think so.
Um,
here's your youtube videos for the week.
We're just blowing through the topics here.
Youtube videos for the week.
A pug.
Pug Sings Batman theme.
Look that one up there,
right?
Pug as in the dog.
PUBG pug as opposed to a Gore pug sings Batman theme.
Um,
drunk ass knock out.
A lot of this shit's going to have to do with alcohol this week.
A wasted guy at Coachella,
Coachella is c o c h e l l a.
And here's one for you,
a do something difficult and you know what?
I actually forgot the most fucked up one of the week.
I have to just bear with me here.
I have my,
the microphone laying on my chest right now.
I want to say somebody used to do that.
Didn't like one of those,
those guys late at night when they're trying to sell you shit before they came
up with the Janet Jackson Mcdonald's drive through headset.
Didn't they have like that hands free device where the microphone just dangled
from your neck?
I want to say that they had that all the other guys,
that's a movie coming out that the other guys,
I actually had an audition for that movie and I got all the way down to the part
where the guy who got the part was fucking,
he,
I think he went in before me and killed it.
So now when I see that movie,
I'm like,
ah,
look.
So fucking funny.
I could've been in there with eight lines.
God dammit.
All right.
The fucking,
all right.
What's the name of this video woman finds man in bed,
something like that.
Oh,
here.
Women.
Woman wakes up to find intruder in her bed.
You gotta see this one?
It's so fucked up.
I don't even know if it's real.
It looks like a fucking in living color sketch.
Um,
all right.
Overrated.
Underrated for this week and the overrated or underrated this week.
Uh,
you guys really took it to another level here.
This is fucking phenomenal.
All right.
Underrated.
Uh,
first kid in your junior high that admitted to jerking off.
That might be one of my favorite underwriters of all time.
What a fucking champ had kid was.
You know,
you know,
some people are still trying to find themselves at 35 or possibly 42,
like myself.
That kid knew the fuck he was in junior high.
Hey,
jerking off I do it.
Fucking feels good.
Fucking rub one out in next class.
I like to teach her.
She's still with something for me.
One,
I'm the last guy in the,
in the,
in the fucking row.
Just don't turn around,
you'll be fine.
Um,
number two,
whoever commented that Roger Ebert now looks like one of the muppets from the
land of Confusion Video Jesus Christ.
On a side note,
that is one of the creepiest videos ever.
Yeah,
man.
Poor Roger Ebert,
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
How ironic is that?
That he spent his life criticizing people and then he gets fucking mouth cancer,
you know,
and he's,
he's still criticizing shit.
He's like,
he's like the God damn a terminator.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
And if that's true,
what the fuck am I going to get?
The fuck's going to happen to me.
All this shit that I spew.
Number three,
Leopold butter's Scotch.
Next to Carmen,
the best character on South Park.
I hope I said the dude's name right.
I love South Park.
I really loved and,
and I'm actually,
I'm going to,
uh,
I'm starting to watch the boondocks because everybody told me that's the shit.
So watch it with me.
And,
uh,
let's watch a quality show together.
What do you say?
People.
Anybody else watching?
Breaking bad.
I can't believe I've been watching it for three fucking seasons and I haven't.
Um,
I haven't,
uh,
haven't really talked about it.
I fucking love it.
It's a God damn.
It's a great show.
But I've yet to get into that advertising.
Mad,
mad,
mad men.
Mad Money.
The fuck is it?
I don't know how everybody walks around smoking.
Um,
I heard it's great and everybody on that shows dressed in suits,
which I like a number four underrated.
This is another great one.
This is a new,
this is this.
This is this person's first contribution to the podcast and a,
I think this person should be a staff writer is another fucking gem number four
station wagons in the 80s with the rear seats facing out the back window.
Kids have everything today,
but they missed out on that one.
Do you know my parents had an 83 caprice classic maroon with the fake wood going
down the side,
top of the line,
the wire wheels,
cloth,
Maroon fucking,
uh,
interior.
We drove all the way out to Chicago one time,
all the way out to Chicago.
I was in the Middle Cup of my siblings were sitting in the back and I was
jealous that they got to sit,
you know,
seeing what we just fucking saw.
And then my parents sat in the front ned bench seat that blocked the AC and they
wouldn't let us put the windows down.
My fucking dad would sit there with his hands in front of the,
you know,
he's hands on the vent like an inch away from the vent feeling the AC coming
out,
you know,
completely fucking selfish.
And will they,
can we turn it on?
We can.
We put the windows down and like,
no,
we got the AC on.
Yeah.
Well the big cloth bench seat is fucking blocking it
and we just sat there looking at farmland whizzing by.
My brother's actually got to stick their heads out the window in the back,
you know,
like a couple of fucking months and I sat there in the,
just had to sit there taking it.
All right.
Number five,
underrated kids in the hall.
Absolutely.
When people bring up the greatest sketch shows of all time,
you know,
they'll say,
Mr show,
they'll say Dave Chappelle and uh,
the people in the know also say kids in the hall.
And I'd have to definitely go with that.
All right.
Overrated.
Humping in the shower apps a Fuckin lutely that's exciting.
When you're in college,
you know that sensation of water,
you know?
Yeah.
Hopping in the shower is weird.
Then the water's hitting her booty crack.
It starts making a weird noise.
You know,
it's a water shoots up from her fucking ass crack.
It's hitting you and your lower jaw,
you know,
who can concentrate.
Um,
number two,
uh,
bartenders that claim to have created their own drink.
Is it ever good?
It's never fucking good.
Uh,
overrated.
Bourbon Street.
I got to go at the end.
That is overrated.
You fucking go down there.
It's a bunch of God damn tours who can't hold their fucking alcohol.
And then there's a bunch of God damn wolves on the side streets waiting to
fucking stick a knife in your neck.
Uh,
also overrated national spelling.
Bee contests are overrated.
Uh,
I dunno,
I dunno if I go,
I actually liked those ones and I think it's great that those kids learn how to
fucking spell.
It's something that I wish I learned how to do and um,
I root for,
I want him to win the spelling bee and I also want them to get laid before the
36.
Um,
and here's a random one.
Go on Google maps and you know when he can hit satellite,
it actually looked down,
you know,
and actually bring yourself down on the street with that little man.
Here's one for you in the middle of France.
This is what you want to look up his,
the address eight are you e which means Street d.
You have duck,
Tia,
[inaudible],
doc,
Jay.
[inaudible].
That was one word.
Uh,
grand y'all,
which means big Joel.
Um,
five,
four zero,
zero,
zero.
Yeah,
Nancy.
N.
A.
C.
Y.
I just realized how long this is and now I can't stop.
I got to give you the whole thing.
Comma,
m e U.
R.
T.
H.
E.
You guys writing this down?
Like Morse code dash e t dash e m o s e l.
L e.
And then Lorraine France,
All right.
Google map that hit the satellite.
Bring the little man down on the street and tell me what the fuck that is on
that porch.
Tell me that's not a fucking alien.
There's an alien on the porch and the satellite cut the picture of it.
I Dunno.
Who knows?
It's probably a goddamn beehive.
That was a fucking way to go.
But I like it.
I take it that it has a lot to do to good theme for this podcast.
You know,
for a hung over son of a bitch with nothing in his,
in his,
in his stomach.
Other than the two slices of pizza that I ate at one in the morning.
La Pizza,
by the way.
See,
you know,
it was good.
Um,
you know,
something I just realized,
I feel like I haven't said anything funny in the last 20 minutes.
How long ago was that?
Clinton Gore with they're bitchy bodies sachet and around the White House.
I know that that was funny.
Uh,
the sound of their milk,
white hips hitting that fucking suit material.
Nationwide healthcare,
just walking around the Oval Office,
both of them,
Eh,
you know something I'm going to,
I'm going to vote them that in my lifetime.
The too bitchy as that's the bitchy as tandem that has ever,
ever been in the White House.
You know what I mean?
I'll tell you right now,
I,
and I didn't vote for him for,
well actually 96.
Actually in 96 I did vote for Clinton,
but after that I've just gone rogue because then Clinton just turned out to be
the same fucking dude that,
that,
that other guy,
the angry guy with the pen Bob Dole.
Right.
Either he did the same shit.
They all do the same shit.
Oh,
you fucking morons who voted for Obama and now you're surprised.
Can you believe he's pretty much doing what Mccain would've done?
And I'm not talking about the is shit,
I'm talking about the Afghans.
Yeah.
I had a fucking,
I don't even know what I'm talking about,
but I'm sick.
All you douchebags bitching about all the taxes.
Do you really think you're going to have to fucking wars?
And at some point when all the rich people get up from the table after they take
fucking show and screw man,
when you did that,
you walked in with your buddies and he ordered a big fucking meal and when the
waitress went up to bar,
y'all ran out the door and you jumped into your fucking AMC Gremlin and drove
away laughing,
laughing your ass off.
And that poor Brian had to pay for it.
Do you know that there's a place in Norwood,
Massachusetts called the Cafe Venice.
And I did that 20 years ago and I still feel guilty about it.
I went in there,
and I'm not going to name names,
but it was a bunch of names,
there's too many names to name.
And we stood up and we were Gunna pay and we,
and the waitress was just not there.
And we just waited and waited and waited and waited.
And I'm like,
where the fuck is she?
And then there was that tension and there was somebody,
there was this weird laugh and somebody out of the group walked out the door and
then there was that panic.
Oh my God.
It was like that musical chair game.
You didn't want to be the last one standing when the music's playing,
playing.
Cause then you got to pay for the check.
And then we all just fucking
just bursted out the door.
And I remember it because it was really dark in the cafe Venice.
I don't even know if it even exists anymore.
And then we went out into the sunlight,
couldn't fucking see shit,
just running towards something that looked like the shape of our car.
Just that young
fucking energy that you had.
We could actually be stuffed with food and still run and laugh and still get
away,
you know?
And we just got in the car and just laughed our asses off the hallway.
And I immediately,
afterwards I felt guilty because I knew that she would have to pay for it.
And uh,
this is how young I was.
I actually ordered a large milk with my Italian meal.
I was like 18 or 19 and I was one of those guys who just never stopped drinking
milk.
I didn't stop drinking milk until I was like,
I dunno.
Somewhere in my fucking late twenties I used to drink.
I loved it.
I loved the nice cold glass of fucking milk.
And I had it with like every meal
and it was,
you know,
my first time at 18 we're all of a sudden,
you're not realizing you're hanging out with the adults.
I just graduated high school and everybody's ordering and they go,
yeah,
let me get,
let me get a,
you know,
some fuck the league,
Tony with the fucking meat sauce over there and I'll get a fucking coke in a
while.
Everyone's ordering coax a bear and blah,
blah,
blah.
And I was like,
uh,
oh,
I have this spaghetti and meatballs and I a have a large milk.
And there was this pause and then the ball breaking began and it never fucking
ended for the rest of it,
you know?
And uh,
whatever.
I Dunno what the fuck I'm saying.
What the fuck am I saying?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
So they,
we got to fucking wars for eight goddamn years.
And then all the corporations got up from the table,
ran out to their fucking,
uh,
top of the line,
bulletproof SUV,
and they drove off and yet they left us with the tab and all you guys think that
we're not going to have to pay it back.
You think the taxes aren't coming to fuck?
They're coming.
Oh,
they're coming.
There you go.
That was my fucking what's going on with the world
now?
Fuck you.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Whatever.
I made it to an hour.
I made another one.
That's all it is.
It's like the drew Carey show the last nine seasons with it just going,
whatever it's syndication money.
Who gives a fuck?
Let's just bring in some fat,
broad with crazy makeup and have drew yell at her when People Watch it.
Great.
We'll all get fucking paid.
We're all going to get fucking paid hate.
Anybody read that story in that magazine?
I think it was Esquire magazine about that guy who fucking went on the prices.
Right?
And like a card counter.
He,
he just,
he broke the bank.
He went both showcases in the 37 years or whatever,
the shock,
the
prices,
right,
has been on the air.
No one has ever guessed the exact amount of the showcase that they bid on and
this guy did it.
And all you have to do is come within 50 bucks or 100 bucks and you win both
showcases.
And this guy,
he fucking,
he nailed bullshit.
He hit it right on the head.
And so the point they thought he was cheating because everybody was winning that
day and they can't figure it out if it was him or if it was this other guy in
the audience who was fucking tip and people off,
cause he would give it away cars.
And I guess the price is right,
has to pay for the prizes.
So evidently drew Carey didn't think that the episode was going to air,
so he was kind of a Dick when he said you won both.
And then I guess they ended up fucking airing it during like a sweeps week.
So he kind of looked like a dick,
but,
uh,
I guess,
prices,
right?
People were not thrilled.
So is this,
this whole article and he's saying the,
uh,
he's only guilty of being an avid fan of the show and the price is right fucked
up by,
they would have reoccurring prices.
I'm Rena reoccurring prizes,
like they had some sort of smoke around there.
One of those eggs,
smokers.
You've,
have you ever seen those?
Fucking thanks.
Um,
and he knew the exact fucking price of it.
So when he was in contestants row,
they will,
like the egg smoker.
Somebody was like 1500 and Egos,
you know?
And if you don't know the exact prices,
somebody says 1500,
you think it's about 1500?
You usually go 1501.
Oh you say 1200 to try to get the next,
you know,
300 in your favor.
He said,
like,
fucking a,
I'm going to go with the 1478.
And he nailed it first.
Fred fucking flat.
Am I really going to go through the whole episode?
It's out there people.
But would have to go to the [inaudible] podcast.com this weekend I'm going to be
down in La Jolla,
California,
just outside of San Diego playing the comedy store,
my home away from home out here in La.
I'm going to do the one down in La Jolla and uh,
bring your ass down there.
I got a brand new hour as shit and uh,
I can not wait to go down there.
I'm going to spend the fucking weekend down there,
get a sunburn on the beach,
maybe do a little golfing.
And uh,
even though I don't golf,
I just like fucking,
you know,
going out there and slowing it down for the other cuts on the course.
And that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all he is.
And uh,
by the way,
in two weeks,
I want to be at the Newport Yannick Center in Newport,
Rhode Island,
and I'm going to be at the Hampton Beach Ballroom Casino in Hampton,
New Hampshire.
Uh,
I got to sell a ton of fucking ticket.
So if you're not doing anything for the love of God,
you and all your friends come on down,
get hammered.
If you're the waitress from the cafe Venice,
please show up.
I'll give you a DVD and I'll give you the fucking 100 bucks with interest that I
owe you from
fucking goddamn 22 years ago.
All right,
everybody have a good week.